[Music]
welcome back to harvard unboxed so the
thumbnail
pretty well said it all but just so no
one can accuse me of clickbait yeah
these are dumb
there i said the thing in the thumbnail
actually to be clear these graphics
cards are very impressive and they work
really well i mean
look how thick this thing is look at the
size of it absolutely massive they're
all very big very impressive graphics
cards
the problem of course is the price and
that has been set by nvidia
and of course it's been set really
really high but we'll get to that in a
moment
before we do
today's video sponsor spot is brought to
you by msi and their z690 series
motherboards made for intel 12th gen
desktop processors a personal favorite
of ours is the pro z690-a
offering strong entry-level vr and
performance loads of usb ports and 2.5
gigabit lan the z690 tomahawk wi-fi is a
great mid-range all-rounder and at the
high end the z690 unifi is an extreme
board packing a 19 phase vrm using 105
amp power stages for the v-core it's a
great board that we use in our elderly
test system for more information please
check the link in the video description
now nvidia's first ampere-based gpus
were released 18 months ago now and that
includes the geforce rtx 3090 a 1500
usmsrp model that i claimed was boring
and rather pointless in my day one
review in short the rtx 3090 made little
sense for gamers there's really no need
for a whopping great 24 megabyte vrm
buffer and despite nvidia's best efforts
8k gaming just isn't a thing at least
not yet unfortunately though over the
last 18 months boring and rather
pointless is a good way of summarizing
the entire graphics card industry and
you can probably include the word
hopeless in there as well that's because
months after the initial release even
stupid products like the rtx 3090 were
nearly impossible to find unless you
were willing to pay scalper prices which
were typically up over three thousand
dollars u.s and that continued right
through until january of this year
pricing has started to drop quite a bit
recently though in many cases we are
still faced with inflated prices still
18 months after release you can now get
3090s for as low as 1900 us over at
places like newegg.com and that's still
almost 30 over msrp but of course it's
well down from the 3 000 plus prices we
were faced with not that long ago
of course the rtx 39 is still a dumb
product for gamers given the original
rtx 3080 can now be had for eleven
hundred dollars us and in some instances
a little bit less meaning you're paying
over seventy percent more for thirty
ninety for what amounts to about 10 to
15 more performance at 4k
still you could argue the rtx 3090 isn't
pointless or all that dumb given it's
the most affordable graphics card you
can get your hands on with a 24 gigabyte
vrm buffer now as i said that is
entirely worthless for gamers but for
certain productivity workloads the big
memory buffer could be a godsend which
workloads that is we're not entirely
sure as that's not the focus of our
content but needless to say if you need
a gpu with 24 gigabytes of vram the rtx
3090 may be of value
so there's that but what about a geforce
rtx 3090 ti
would a ti version packing two and a
half percent more cores clocked ten
percent higher with eight percent more
memory bandwidth be useful to anyone i
guess that depends on the price and of
course it's not replacing the original
non-ti version at fifteen hundred
dollars u.s
this isn't a refresh where you get a
small boost at the same price point
before the next generation arrives
rather this is what i'd call a milking a
small performance bump for a big price
hike a hike that sees the msrp hit two
thousand dollars u.s
so apart from a few extra cores the
390ti is just an overclocked 3090 with a
ludicrously higher power rating of 450
watts and almost 30 percent increase
over the original 3090 and as i just
mentioned it costs over 30 percent more
based on the msrp and of course you can
rest assured it won't be anywhere near
30 faster
so is that dumb
sure sounds like it but let's go over
the
benchmarks in total i've tested 12 games
at 1080p 1440p and 4k but running a look
at the 4k data with the rest of the
graphs available to floatplane and petro
members but of course the dozen game
average data will be included in this
video
as for the testing we're again using our
ryzen 9 5950x gpu test system which has
been configured with 32 gigabytes of
dual rank dual channel ddr4 3200 cl 14
memory please note resizable bar isn't
enabled as we view this is more of a
platform feature that isn't suitable for
individual gpu tests at least at this
point in time as it doesn't accurately
represent how radeon and geforce gpus
compare on older systems that are just a
generation old okay let's get in the
data
starting with assassin's creed valhalla
we see that both the asus and msi 39eti
models were good for 69 fps on average
making them just three percent faster
than the original rtx 3090 as well as
the radeon rx 6900 xt so a disappointing
result there but let's move on in hope
that things improve
next we have far cry 6 and here the new
39eti models were just five percent
faster than the rtx 3090 founders
edition or just two and a half percent
faster than the supreme x version of the
standard 3090. so we're still looking at
mid to low single digit gains for these
new ti models
watchdogs legion also shows a mere five
percent increase over the stock 3090 or
three percent over the supreme x version
as both the msi and asus 3090ti cards
rented 66 fps on average an impressive
4k result for sure
but hardly earth shattering when
compared to what we got 18 months ago at
a much lower price point
the margins did grow a little bit in
shadow of the tomb raider here the 30 90
ti supreme x was 11 faster than the 30
90 fe card though just eight percent
faster than the supreme x version so as
far as the apples to apples comparisons
go the 3090 ti was up to eight percent
faster than the 3090 so some pretty
uninspiring gains there
at face value the tom clancy's rainbow
six siege results look more promising
with larger margins but that's mostly
down to the fact that we're playing with
much larger numbers here still the
supreme x 3090 ci was three and a half
percent faster than the asus tough
gaming oc model
though it was only nine percent faster
than the older supreme x version of the
original 3090.
f1 2021 sees an eight percent margin
from the 3090 super max to the 3090ti
version so that seems to be about as
good as it gets for the 3090ti
i should note that the radeon gpus look
quite weak here as ray tracing is
enabled by default and therefore we do
test with this rendering feature enabled
no surprises were found in horizon zero
dawn the 3090 ti was just five percent
faster than comparable 3090 models
rendering 98 fps on average
do maternal was no challenge for the 390
ti though the same was also true for the
30 90 and here the supreme x models are
separated by a mere four percent margin
oh this is exciting the 3090 ti supreme
x was 11 percent faster than the 3090
supremax i think that is our biggest
margin yet clearly this game enjoyed the
higher clocked cause and memory i'm not
sure you'll really notice going from 123
fps to 138 fps at 4k
but you'll probably notice the 500 plus
missing from your wallet
moving on there's little to be seen in
death stranding here the supermax models
are separated by a mere six percent
margin
hitman 3 risks a little excitement with
a 9 margin favoring the 30 90 ti supreme
x over the 3090 model so almost double
digit margins there
finally we have cyberpunk 2077 with a 10
performance boost over the supreme x
3090 so that's about as good as it gets
sadly we couldn't hit 60 fps in our test
using the second highest quality
settings so maybe next generation
hardware will be able to achieve that at
4k
based on that it does sound as though
the 390ti is up to 10 faster than the
original 3090 at 4k
and to make sure we'll take a look at
the 12 game average data but we'll do so
and not just 4k but also 1440p and 1080p
starting with the 1080p data you can see
despite using the ryzen 9 5950x with low
latency memory we're still largely cpu
bound at this lower resolution with
average frame rates in excess of 200 fps
so there's probably not much point
comparing the 3090 and 3090 ti here
for those of you targeting 1440p with
ultra light quality settings the 390ti
appears to be on average just four
percent faster than equivalent 3090
models see when comparing the msi
supreme x cards
then at 4k we're looking at a 7
performance improvement when comparing
the msi supreme x models so very
underwhelming indeed the 390ti was 20
faster than the 600 xt so there is that
but we're talking about a stock 1600 xt
so you could probably have that margin
with a good overclocker so in summary
the 390ti wasn't even 10 faster than the
original 1390 but the msrp has been
jacked up by 33
so what about power usage
well we know the board power rating has
increased by almost 30 percent to 450
watts and that saw total system usage
rise by an insane 18
to 702 watts for the supreme x model up
from just shy of 600 watts with the
original 30 90. that is a horrible
increase for just seven percent more
performance on average
now before we wrap up this review let's
take a closer look at the asus gamewood
and msi rtx 3090ti graphics cards that
we had on hand for testing and we'll
start with the asus tough gaming oc
model the rtx 3090 version was very
large but unsurprisingly the 3090 ti is
even bigger weighing
1677 grams which isn't that crazy in
terms of weight but the dimensions
really are quite something measuring 325
millimeters long 150 millimeters tall
and a whopping 63 millimeters wide
making this a three slot graphics card
externally it really does look like any
other 30 series tough gaming graphics
card there are three 100 millimeter fans
wrapped in an aluminium shroud and on
the back side you get a full-size
aluminium backplate the stainless steel
i o bracket features three display port
outputs and two hdmi outputs then
getting down to the pcb we find a pcie
5.0 16 pin power connector and since no
power supplies support this connector
yet at least none that you can buy right
now though they have been announced the
3090 ti's come with an adapter that
feeds three 8-pin pcie cables into the
pci 5.0 16 pin power connector this is
basically the same 12 pin connector that
was featured on all nvidia foundation 30
series models but with just four extra
sense pins
probably the biggest upgrade for all 30
90 ti graphics cards though is the
memory although the capacity hasn't
changed from the original 3090 so still
24 gigabytes the memory density and
frequency has improved upgrading the
memory module's capacity from one
gigabyte to 2 gigabyte meaning there are
just 12 memory modules now not 24 and
that means they're all on the front side
of the pcb and this will significantly
improve memory cooling performance
it also means that the back plate is now
just extracting heat from the rear of
the pcb and not also a dozen gddr6x
memory chips asus has still included
plenty of thermal pads on the back plate
though using it as a heat spreader the
heatsink is massive as you'd expect and
asus has gone with a nickel plated
copper base for extracting heat from the
gpu and some of the gddr6x memory for
whatever reason most of the memory chips
are connected to an aluminium plate
rather than the copper base which won't
be as efficient for extracting heat
still overall a very good looking cooler
with an excellent mounting method for
connecting it with the pcb
when put to the test installed in the
corsair obsidian 500d in a 21 degree
room the tough gaming peaked at just 79
degrees for the hotspot with a peak
memory temperature of 78 degrees the
fans spun at 2400 rpm and the cores
typically clocked at 1.99 gigahertz so
basically two gigahertz out of the box
also included for our day one coverage
is the msi rtx 3090ti supreme x and my
word this thing is a beast it's without
question the biggest graphics card i've
ever come across taking up four slots
with a weight of
2145 grams it measures 305 millimeters
long and stands 140 millimeters tall but
as i said at 71 millimeters wide it
takes up four slots complete madness
this one
there are three 95 millimeter fans
encased in a pretty bonkers looking fan
shroud and at the re is an incredible
looking back plate that has really a lot
going on there's brushed aluminium led
backlit logos vents and a neat looking
black skirt at the end oddly though
despite the massive i o bracket which
takes up three slots msi has only
included three display port outputs and
a single hdmi output so one less hdmi
port than what you get on the asus model
where the supremex appears to be in a
league of its own though is that
gigantic cooler man this thing is next
level whereas the asus tough gaming was
a combination of heatsink fins and
aluminium brackets the supreme x is
pretty much all fins there's eight
nickel plated heat pipes that extend
throughout the fin stacks and connecting
the gpu and gddr6x memory to the
heatsink is a very large nickel plated
base and in this example it makes
contact with all 12 memory modules
finally when put to the test installed
inside the core strip ct500d again in a
21 degree room the supreme x picked at
88 degrees for the hot spot with a
memory peak temperature of 82 degrees
but crucially it is worth noting that
the fans spun at just 1700 rpm so the
supreme x was virtually silent
the cores again typically clocked at
1.99 gigahertz so again basically two
gigahertz out of the box
now unfortunately i only received the
gainwood rtx 390 ti phantom gs the day
before our review was set to go live
which is why i didn't include any
results in our graphs but i did have
time to install in our test system and
run it for an hour for a temperature
analysis but before we get to those
results let's take a quick look at the
card
as you'd expect this is another triple
slot design there are three 90
millimeter fans embedded in the plastic
shroud it's a cool looking design and
there are some black anodized pipes that
run end to end and they look a bit
industrial then around the back is a
full-size back plate with some air vents
cut out towards the end in fact it's
quite a large section of the back plate
as the pcb is very short gamewed has
managed to cramp their premium rtx
3090ti graphics card onto a 205
millimeter long pcb which is impressive
given the card is 310 millimeters long
in total this means there is quite a
large section of the card that allows
air to pass through and this should help
quite a lot with cooling performance
like msi gamewood has gone with a single
hdmi output but there are also three
display port outputs as well and of
course there is a single 16 pin pci 5.0
power connector
now the phantom gaming gs is quite heavy
at 1837 grams thanks to a large triple
slot cooler packing eight heat pipes and
a large copper base
gamewood's been very generous with the
thermal pads and there's a good amount
of them found on the back plate so
overall a solid looking 3090 ti when put
inside our corsair obsidian 500d in a 21
degree room the phantom gs peaked at 84
degrees for the hot spot with a peak
memory temperature of 76 degrees these
temperatures were achieved with a fan
speed of 1850 rpm so in terms of cooling
performance the phantom gs doesn't
appear to be all that dissimilar to the
absolutely massive msi supreme x
the core is also typically clocked at 2
gigahertz so a fraction height that of
the asus and msi models though the
difference here is negligible
right so at this point i can sense a few
nvidia fans saying something like what
about ray tracing and dlss why haven't
you talked about those is it because
you'll like the 600xt maybe it is isn't
it admit it just admit it
no it's not because i like the 600xt if
you think that's the case then you
probably haven't watched my 6900xt
review the reason i haven't talked about
or even shown ray tracing and dlss
benchmark numbers is because
i don't want to it's pointless i'm
pretty well pretty bored at this point
i've shown you the benchmark numbers of
how it compares the rasterization
performance how it compares to the 30 90
and ray tracing and dlss is going to
scale no differently there just tack on
a few percentage points and you'll have
your 30 90 ti numbers so yeah we've had
the 3090 for like 18 months now as i've
said numerous times so if you want to
know how the 39eti performs in ray
tracing and dls's performance well go
have a look at the 3090 as i said add a
few percentage points on there and
you'll have your answer there is
absolutely nothing new here in terms of
ray tracing and dlss that really is the
problem with the geforce rtx 3090 ti in
a nutshell it's an 18 month old product
that's 18 months late to the party but
despite that manages to cost 33 more for
at best around 10 more performance while
managing to suck down almost 30 percent
more power
in my opinion 3090 ti really does define
modern overclocking for gamers it's hot
layout expensive and ultimately
pointless the original 3090 makes far
less sense and it's really quite
something when the new tli model makes
the original dumb product look all smart
and sensible but that's exactly what the
3090ti has done it's made me look back
at the 3090 and say well you weren't
that stupid after all but then i
remember it's just 14 faster than the
original 3080 with 114 increase to the
msrp and then i just get confused and
can't work out which 3090 is the dumbest
they've both just got so much going for
them in the look how silly i am
department
speaking of silly the nvidia review
guide for the geforce rtx 3090 ci really
is something nvidia claims that the
point of comparison for the 3090 ti is
the titan rtx you know that two and a
half thousand dollar turing-based gpu
that was released in late 2018 almost
four years ago now
if the rtx 3090 didn't already exist
with 24 gigabytes of vram then you could
certainly make that argument but it does
and has done so for 18 months now
nvidia goes on to say when we launched
the original titan rtx it clocked in at
two and a half thousand dollars in
comparison the rtx 390ti is on average
55 faster if you don't have a titan rtx
gpu to compare against let us know and
we can provide performance data to
supplement your coverage
boy i hope no reviewer was silly enough
to take them up on that offer
nvidia then for reasons we simply don't
understand decided to double down by
continuing to push the 8k gaming angle
why nvidia no one bought the 8k gaming
thing in the first place well apart from
the reviewers that you paid to promote
that nonsense 8k gaming isn't a thing
for a few reasons firstly what 8k gaming
monitors are they promoting this for
also they say the rtx 3090 ti lets you
play capture and watch your games in
brilliant 8k hdr with dlss ultra
performance mode for 8k gaming
no because dlss ultra performance mode
isn't 8k gaming 8k gaming would be 8k
gaming not a scaled up version using
dlss that aside though the fact remains
that when using dulled down quality
settings on cyberpunk 2077
with the ray tracing completely disabled
the 3090ti couldn't achieve 60 fps at
even 4k so i don't think it's 8k ready
in this title with any level of dlss
support
man the 8k gaming thing became such a
point of mockery after the rtx 3090
launch god tier meme status stuff and
yet nvidia's marketing team is like yep
that was well received let's do it again
another 18 months later with a product
that's barely any faster bravo
nvidia then went on to talk about how
the 3090 ti is a content creator's dream
gpu they barely mention gaming beyond
the stupid 8k meme stuff it was just
comparisons with the old titan rtx and
rtx 2080 ti in productivity workloads
stuff we're not really interested in
here and even if we were as i said the
24 gigabyte rtx 3090 is still a thing
anyway i think i'll pretty well leave it
there
had the 3090 ti slotted in around the
original 3090 price point then
you know might have been an okay release
not amazing again we are talking about
18 month old hardware here
but the release wouldn't have been
entirely horrible of course i am very
very keen to hear what you guys think
about the 39 ti
and with that i'll be heading to the
comment section to make sure i read
everything that you guys have to say
about these new graphics cards
and with that uh yeah like subscribe if
you did enjoy the the review do hit that
like button for us that helps a lot
subscribe because yeah always more
content coming up worth watching and if
you'd like to get some more
behind-the-scenes action some more
insights and stuff like that then feel
free to check out floatplane or patreon
you've got access to our exclusive
discord server monthly live streams a
team myself a q a's and then yep behind
the scenes content so a lot of cool
stuff there if you're interested check
those links out as i said they are in
the video description but if not
perfectly fine and thank you for
watching this video i'm your host steve
and i'll see you again next time
[Music]
you